hi green wilson we saw and here we go
the first move first move liam opens
with the queen's pawn he tends to do
this his favorite move since he was the
youngster
black brings his night out okay what is
lee i'm gonna go for will we see another
london system we've seen a few of those
in this tournament where we see queen's
gambit there we go
and liam not playing something
recommended in his chessable course i
would have loved to see magnus face
another london system
uh he struggled yesterday against
lebanon there meanwhile it's instead the
catalan
this is magnus's favorite opening these
days as white liam are doing
doing magnus things against magnus
and that has caused black to pause
a variety of ways here that black can
react he can give a check with his dark
squared bishop he can capture
the kind of queen's gambit pawn the pawn
that's been gambled on c4 black can
develop in a bunch of ways
seems to be very popular the catalan
nowadays i mean it's always been quite
popular but um i mean it seems to be
rising popularity do you think i mean
you you play it we mentioned that a lot
of the english grand masters play it uh
niche plays it a lot and uh yeah it's
it's a good way to
get that bishop to a fantastic square
for the rest of the game i mean if you
just compare the two bishops have been
developed white's bishop has much better
potential than black's bishop for across
the board striking through the middle
and i think that's why white tends to do
this positional opening yeah very
positional opening i think it's the
perfect opening for players who prefer
slower games general strategy sometimes
it's symmetrical it's just about the
power of that white light square bishop
and i was waiting for the first surprise
there was no way magnus was going to
play the main line there and capture
white's pawn that's just not magnus's
style
instead he gains space this is more uh
carlsonesque he just loves gaining space
with pawns in any sort of position
um he's just hinting that maybe that
blackball would advance further getting
the black rook in the corner a bit more
active
just generally gaining space it doesn't
have a great reputation this move as far
as i know but
i probably haven't looked as deeply as
magnus
yeah now i i've also heard and seen that
it doesn't have a great reputation and i
thought it was because of this move you
know where white just puts the knight on
its most aggressive outpost and uh
usually black reacts to this night move
by capturing the pawn but here
not so easy to capture that pawn without
making big concessions yeah magnus
decides not to try and be greedy not to
capture any pawns he just
uh kind of makes this stronghold in the
center with his structure this is what
we kind of call the triangle pawn
formation in the middle of the board
where black just has these pawns all on
light squares normally we get it from
different openings but
um yeah it's a bit passive
white normally will get the chance to
expand a bit more in the center
one of the problems i guess was triangle
situation is again if you look at the
bishops
um black's light square bishop whenever
you go for the structure like in the
slav the semi-slav the triangle which is
a combination of those the the bishop is
is pretty horrendous isn't it just stuck
by behind that formation so you gotta
you gotta try to play with that bad
piece for the rest of the game uh on the
other hand i suppose black might be
threatening to take a pawn so white's
gotta deal with that but i kind of feel
like you know in general black should be
slightly worse uh just because of the
pieces uh his pieces are are worse than
white's pieces there
yeah you're right this pawn may be
attacked um there's a few ways to defend
it one idea would be for example to
advance the queen forward and try to
expand in the center say if black plays
a passive move here
then maybe the white pawn can step
forward and this is kind of typical in
the catalan this is white's dream
to kind of obtain these three pawns in
the center forcing black to commit
and usually black captures this pawn in
the center and this would be a lot of
suffering for black white has space
these pawns are fantastic and as simon
mentions the key fact
is that black's bishop is just terrible
it will never break out past its own
pawns
compared to its counterpart here which
has a great scope on the diagonal and
okay he doesn't go for this liam he does
just sacrifice the pawn at least
temporarily he brings his bishop out
i guess the idea if pawn takes pawn is
that he wants to bring his knight into
the center and regain this guy
it's going to be very difficult for
black to keep this pawn intact for
example just to illustrate the power of
white's catalan bishop this beautiful
bishop fianchettoed on g2
now white would be able to
take this pawn and win some material win
this rook in the corner this is quite a
typical pattern
and uh white would be doing very well so
i don't think we'll see magnus capture
nope uh instead he just develops his
knight very solid
it's very solid but it's it's also very
passive i mean uh i just i i mean i i'd
hate to play this kind of position as
black because that bishop uh the only
way you can try to get that bishop out
that i can see is by fianchettoing
which takes quite a lot of time and even
when you fee in chateau um you've got to
try to break the pawns get those pawns
off the light squares
so i i if i was white here i'd be trying
to be a bit patient i think um because i
can play against that bishop forever i
love your idea david of trying to push
the pawn in the middle and moving the
queen two squares is very very tempting
uh i mean even move the knight back in
front of the queen
with the same idea it might not be
ridiculous here and i know this this is
an idea that uh white often uses in
these types of positions as well because
you want to give the white bishop
white's light square bishop more range
and to do that getting rid of white
black's pawn in the middle of the board
will will open up the range of that
bishop so it's just the bishops to me
white has stable advantage here i'd say
yeah and a bunch of moves to choose from
for liam i think bring his queen forward
maybe dropping his knight back he could
just be very very patient kind of push
his pawn forward defend this guy
either way
liam with the advantage magnus very
cramped very passive
will the world champion be able to break
out a bit later that's the big question
liam instead just improves his rook very
calm very patient looking nice for white
yeah
looking very solid and uh for black and
uh i do like what you guys suggest where
just you play in the center that's
always the most thematic way in my
experience
and uh whilst magnus is pausing for
thoughts
well we do have a selfie competition
where we're asking you to tweet us a
selfie that will impress
our chess experts grandmaster david howe
and the winner will get david's
chestable course grind like a
grandmaster that heated together with
magnus coulson and leone says
well sends us a hello from kenya just
from school in time to watch my role
model pragnanda whilst reading for my
exams hopefully i won't be grounded like
him
it reminds me that he ever played a
tournament while he had to read for the
exams the following day because remember
he did that he was playing in the final
and had exams the next day and and he
actually even had to take those exams
yeah he did yeah i never actually asked
him how he did maybe we'll have to get
smart i bet he i bet he ate those exams
i'm sure he but doesn't really matter
right
no he's his future yes exactly
well actually sometimes these exams are
super important and they they don't let
you go on in life until you've actually
asked them that's harsh yeah
pretty sure the grandmaster title was
more important than
some crappy exams
they wouldn't hold him back i don't
think it'd be like no you can't play
chess ever again until you pass this
exam
there's some exams right in the in the
uk where you have to pass
not to be a chess grandmaster
i mean uh yeah i mean
i don't know are they and what you want
to do in life i guess yeah yeah i
suppose so so gcses maybe yeah you have
to do them don't you you have to do them
you have to do like math science english
and then you have to pass one of those
core ones and
yeah i know a couple of grandmasters who
got kicked out of school for failing
exams really many years ago
i actually think magnus carlsen he never
finished uh what would be the american
equivalent of high school i think
i don't think you actually finished yeah
don't try this at home kids stay in
school stay in school but uh
yeah prague multi-talented guy yeah
meanwhile black has captured a pawn
magnus has gone greedy i guess he had no
other
kind of alternative he needed something
to suffer for in this position you might
as well suffer with a lack of space with
a bad bishop uh by being a pawn up i i
don't know why liam allowed this because
uh you didn't need to allow this you
didn't need to unbalance the position i
mean if you try to win the pawn back now
black can defend it with a knight
um so it seems a bit unnecessary to to
allow this possibility when it what you
know you just didn't have you didn't
need to do this
why give your opponent a pawn that you
can maybe sort of hold on to now
there are safe ways to play and you know
i like taking risks when i play chess
but
the analogy is you should always take
the safe option if it's a good option
you know there's no point risking it
just for the sake of it and this just
seems to be this rook move a little bit
off the right the right track i'd say
yeah me i agree with you there simon uh
the rook is somehow a little looking a
little bit strange on that square but on
the other hand i have to say in my
experience catalan players they do love
to give up pawns
and sit on their positional space
advantage and just go what you're gonna
do i mean they're not really like
outright attackers so to speak they just
sit
sit and just hold the position down for
black um
i actually really dread taking that pawn
although i will do it if you push me
i'm glad next time i next time i play
you vancouver i tried to get greedy
against you simon and i ended up mainly
getting checkmated and it was only
because i don't know i was riding some
lucky star there that i didn't get yeah
i remember about that still get the cold
sweats so yeah
i i understand why white's done this and
liam is a very aggressive player he's
not scared to sacrifice and he loves
attacking but
um you're making it like a free result
game as in you're a pawn down if your
attack doesn't work you'll lose to
magnus carlsen being a pawn down he
didn't need to do this you know he could
have had the same kind of thing a bit
slower but have an extra pawn so just
just
you know why why do this it seems a
little bit
risky to me and i love taking risks but
not unnecessary ones really i agree
completely with you simon i don't think
i would have even dreamt of that rook
move we were looking at kind of
defending the pawn and planning to
expand in the center
if you if you've already done the hard
work got the advantage got nice pieces
yeah just i mean just play it safe just
uh
there's no need to risk that advantage
and okay white has expanded in the
center white has two very nice pawns in
the middle
i'm slightly curious as well magnus we
saw his screen a few moments ago while
you guys were chatting and
okay magnus is choosing a song it looks
like on his screen he just minimized
the uh the browser there
he's clearly choosing his music i was
gonna say i'm confused why he's thinking
he was about to push his pawn to b5
instantly as soon as liam kind of
expanded in the center magnus was ready
to react but then he changed his mind
he's been sitting here for two minutes
what else could magnus be thinking about
maybe if we jump in we can try and get
inside the world champion's brain i'm
not sure what he's listening to i wish
we knew but uh he was about to play this
move instantly magnus pushing his pawn
two squares forward
makes sense defending his extra pawn
here maybe uh destabilizing the white
knight if he gets the opportunity is he
potentially scared of white breaking in
the center i guess he just has gone into
calculation mode the world champion he
needed some tunes there to get pumped up
in order to calculate this whiteboard
stepping forward
and it's just about whether black is
ready for this the center is about to
explode and whose pieces are
better placed
i guess black can capture this pawn in a
variety of ways
and there's a big threat of stepping
forward again trapping this black bishop
so
maybe you need to remove the pawn one
more time and we could see a bunch of
exchanges and suddenly the position that
we see on the analysis board is
completely different to the position we
see uh on the kind of real-time board
but this is the type of position that
magnus has in his mind he's just trying
to weigh up if all the
pawns all the pieces get exchanged can
he survive here it does look a bit scary
this wreck is attacked in the corner
at the very least as well this pawn is
attacked white's rooks are getting ready
to kind of come to the center of the
board
so um i mean on the superficial level
looks pretty good for white this one
maybe that's why magnus has changed his
mind and if we go back to the current
position
instead of pushing his pawn allowing
that big breakthrough allowing all those
exchanges
what else could he be considering maybe
you'll move simon bring the knight to
this square
just to stop this pawn push but it is
again a bit superficial you kind of want
to put your knight here but only after
having pushed this pawn
yeah yeah i mean don't get me wrong i
still quite like liam's position i mean
i love sacrificing this pawn generally
having these two pawns in the center i
always go for this kind of structure
so i like white but it's just a bit
unnecessary but
finding the next move black is not easy
saying that i mean uh i i'm you know
look looking also at the a pawn because
what else can you do you know i mean
you either push the b pawn now
or you move a piece or you push another
pawn and i don't know it's like it's not
easy to find another move right
in the position maybe maybe you maybe
you can push that a pawn um
possibly uh when pushing the b pawn
would be
even better for black then because
you've got this majority of pawns coming
forwards and
the idea here is if you if you now if
white captures that pawn you get a pawn
in the middle uh a central pawn would be
very nice to capture destroying white
center so this
could be uh the other idea that black's
thinking of maybe yeah
and
i like your move simon you know it's
kind of greed you know taking as much
space as possible i was also thinking
about
waiting with making any form of
commitment so moves that i was
considering is just move the rook to the
e8 square another one is maybe to
push the pawn against the king it's a
luxury move you know maybe black
can't afford to make a move like this
but um i was also that was also on my
radar just to wait and see this would be
a very magnus move just pushing a pawn
here but it does look a bit slow
and this blackrook move looks
potentially useful but for now it looks
i mean it's not the first move that
comes to mind maybe because it's a bit
mysterious if the center doesn't open
okay he goes back he goes through it
yeah he pushes his pawn but he was about
to play this five minutes ago magnus
just spent over five minutes uh
calculating what's gonna happen and okay
we're gonna see the position explode
whoa and the evaluation bar does not
like magnus what magnus has done okay
going back slightly but still in white's
favor things are gonna open up maybe
to the benefit of this bishop which is
sitting innocently
in magnus he's taking the time to choose
the music or i'm not sure if that was
liam
drama happening inside miami arena we're
gonna take a quick trip to miami to uh
svada what's happening in miami now's
weather
well we've been stunned with an
impressive chest but what i'm stunned by
right now is probably the most
impressive pastry chef i've seen in my
life this is niranja pereira and he's
making first of all he's making chess
pieces he's making a chess board and and
this is absolutely spectacular niranjan
how do you do this
yeah i was doing this in like 20 years
so everything is a practice you know
so i work this hotel like seven years
right now
so i love to work this kind of work
that's my specialty
and this is really eden rock hotels here
way of welcoming this chess tour this is
some of the top and foremost chefs they
have working here either if it's the
restaurant or if it is the pastry chef
like mr pereira and and how do you even
go about beginning because i can't see
that you have any you have no
no no outline you're just doing this
from your head are you yeah that's right
everything come to my head so i create
whatever i like
so
somebody give me an idea so i improvise
what i can do
so i like to this is my profession i
like this
i don't know i understand that you like
it but i am just in awe of what is
actually possible here because i i can
tell you one thing i would not in any
shape way or form be able to eat this
masterpiece when it's actually finished
i know it's just too beautiful
everything you can edible
say everything chocolate
wow
i agree about it that's just
wow i mean he must be a chess player
chef preda because to be able to carve
out out of his own imagination yeah
totally i mean this is incredible but i
hate to break it to you i would eat it
yeah i know i would do it
because that chocolate you looked
exactly yeah
and i would eat it with a great delight
and i would probably reach for one more
you know
eat the queen and like the whole chest
white queen
i know you would eat the whole
chessboard simon you love your cake
i do i love my cakes i'm always eating
the norwegian cake
really got a rested fruit and cake if
you remember one time i remember you
brought out the supermarket without
paying for it thought i'd pay for it
didn't mean to steal the cake but uh i'm
now known as the oslo cake thief so um
but yeah it looks amazing what he's
doing they're really impressive but i i
don't know if he knows what chessboard
looks like it's a bit longer than that
you know i'm very critical that's a bit
harsh you know but um yeah he was just
showing a pretty checkmate just on one
segment of the board yeah
it was beautiful beautiful work there so
uh we need him over here yeah i know we
need a cake that's a chess cake
very yummy and uh cool to see it's all
about chess on miami beach and in the
eden rock and nobu hotel it's all about
chess inside the miami arena as well
david
said this position is about to explode
open what's happening it has exploded
the whole center has just disappeared a
bunch of pawns disappeared from that
middle of the board black is still one
point up but magnus has had to resort to
playing some really weird kind of wacky
moves black's rook now normally we
develop knights bishops first but
black's rook has kind of just swung down
the board
i think this was necessary he needed to
cover some very important squares
but also that black rook as we showed in
an earlier variation it was long term a
target for white's light squared bishop
in the corner so it needed to run to
safety and that move did cost magnus a
lot of time he's down now to under six
minutes on the clock he was shaking his
head a moment ago while we were
um just admiring that chocolate
and uh it's up to liam now
remember white is upon down he needs
something energetic he needs to kind of
gain some compensation immediately
before magnus is able to organize
consolidate his extra pawn
and yeah magnus needs maybe two or three
moves
just to get his pieces to better squares
just to get a bit more active maybe
trade off some pieces which would favor
black
what can liam do in the meantime there's
a bunch of threats he could make here
liam but i don't see anything kind of
concrete it looks like a lot of one move
threats
do you guys see anything here that's
tempting for white um yeah i i would be
tempted actually to get the bishop pair
and
then just centralize the night
okay just take this bishop off the board
that's a check black will recapture and
then we centralize hitting this pawn
looks very good heading towards our
dream square yep the f5 square with
great attacking potential and maybe even
heading towards this square
look at this bishop i mean it cuts the
board in half
combined with its fellow here you
control all the squares these two
bishops this looks very promising this
this simple idea and again simple is
good you know let's remember i think it
was uh tony miles you know who had this
i mean i never met tony i don't know if
you guys had a chance he was britain's
first ever grand master um and um
i heard some stories about him he liked
complex positions but he was very famous
saying simple is good just take the
simple option if there's something
simple and scary just play it
especially when a time is short and i
really like this idea this looks like a
very simple and good move yeah
take this bishop off and uh the other
moves that might come to mind maybe
flicking in this bishop attack against
the queen first but i'm not sure what it
achieves the queen does have one safe
square and i don't really see how you
can kind of continue the initiative for
example you can pin uh you can pin this
bishop but uh this would invite maybe in
exchange or maybe black's rook could
swing across to the defense now
um maybe this is one thing that liam's
considering maybe the problem is he
wants to keep it simple but there's just
too many tempting moves another idea is
to bring the knight to this square
hitting the rook hitting this pawn as
well
um yeah there's a bunch a bunch of ideas
but i like your on your wanker um just
simple and safe take this bishop off
centralize your pieces
yeah i'm burning a lot of time now
catching up with magnus on the clock
yeah maybe too many tempting options as
you say david i mean moving to bishop
here moving to work but um i i think you
know you've got it you've got to play
practically haven't you if you do see a
good move you could get carried away
with
all the possibilities but um taking the
bishop is always going to give you
enough compensation for the one pawn
you're down
because you have these fantastic bishops
and again we're talking about black's
light square bishop it has the potential
to move but it still hasn't moved and
it's still going to struggle to move
in that last variation so there's many
small problems and i don't think magnus
will be very happy
with this position right what song is he
going to put on zoom in here yeah can we
see it magnus has his priorities
straight
back to the music while liam thinks
he needs something fast he needs
something
to get him motivated magnus mentioned he
was in trouble in the last game he
managed to escape from that trouble uh
he might need to do the same again did
anyone catch it i didn't catch that any
of our viewers more eagle-eyed than us
maybe prodigy
he needs something uh positive energetic
and i'm just reading this uh tweet
actually that we saw that um we're
talking about uh leaving school with no
edge with no formal qualifications and
fisher left school as without completing
his high school
and uh as pointed out by one of our
uh audience um he had an iq of 181 yeah
that's always kirk it's rookie numbers
have you ever tested your iq david it's
probably 1.81 no it's probably very high
is it is it like that i remember i asked
some of the players once is it like that
that chess players will in general have
a higher iq than
the average in the population i know
some stupid ones yeah i have to say you
know
i mean you might be good at playing
chess but i also like simon i knew a
grand master
who could not pack i mean can you
imagine that and uh there's a famous
story that hal he didn't i mean it just
plays a name for not driving cars and
how you know he just could not drive a
car and whenever someone got in the car
to drive he would just look at them like
whoa
you're like the cleverest person on
earth he's probably too drunk wasn't he
i mean i'm joking he likes his drinking
iq anyway
driving a car yeah that's the
yeah right practical i mean high iq low
eq maybe and i i'm always a bit uh you
know i'm not really sure these iq tests
are very valid because i mean you can
you can i don't know are they a good
indication of intelligence i don't think
i'm not sure to be honest so
yeah okay he's played another move david
meanwhile he went for ivanka's first
move trading off the night for the
bishop uh so white has the bishop pearl
we've talked about that a lot today but
a very
important factor and white is just
trying to kind of undermine with a
minority attack those black pawns on the
left flank white has two against blacks
three but those black three might become
weak after a bunch of exchanges
and uh
okay black's queen jumping in
makes some sense evaluation part again
not a fan but magnus played that one
very quickly we saw his screen a moment
ago he was highlighting his queen he had
a bunch of squares he could have chosen
but this
is the most active for the queen
maybe i mean he could go for something
along the lines of your idea from
earlier ivanka the white knight could
jump into the center now or maybe after
a pawn exchange first
it does feel like white's pieces are
just so perfectly placed it feels like
there must be some
something you can kind of achieve with
them but i don't really see it yet
magnus
he kind of has these level on erroneous
nights like we saw in the last game
where the two black knights just defend
each other they keep a lot of squares
covered
it's just about whether you can
overwhelm the black army at some point
black's pieces especially that bishop as
well terrible but defending
maybe defensively they're okay
yeah uh definitely a tense moment here
in the position and uh whilst liam is
thinking about a way to conduct his
attack
um well we do have a selfie competition
where we're asking to
some people for our audience to tweet a
selfie that will impress grandmaster
david howell and stufftasticness says
i've just printed my first chess set can
you and magnus teach me how the night
moves you know nights are very important
in magnus's game right now
and very impressive 3d printing okay
and meanwhile we have a move from liam
he has retreated the bishop to attack
the queen i wasn't expecting that you
know somehow i was in the mentality of
go forward
yeah that's very surprising is i'm not
sure whether that's ambitious or whether
it's just an attempt to simplify things
black's queen has a choice of two pawns
to capture right now um she is under
fire
which pawn would you guys capture i mean
if magnus for example wants to play it
safe could he simply
get rid okay i was gonna say this exact
pawn the exact move that magnus has
played this pawn is the one doing the uh
putting on the pressure here you can
trade off the queens magnus has done so
remember he's a grinder he likes to
grind out these end games he's in an end
game now and he's still a pawn up uh
temporarily at least this pawn is
probably going to drop magnus says okay
i'm going to counter attack against your
pawn
if for example here all of the pawns are
eliminated on this side then most likely
it will be a draw it's just three pawns
against three pawns
but uh white maybe has a small advantage
with the bishop pair despite the
simplified nature
this is what magnus is hoping for he's
got a bank on the fact he can draw this
position but uh if you're liam here do
you eliminate these two for white one or
do you try and keep white one on the
board there's also a secondary threat of
a bishop skewer on the two white rooks
or maybe you have to go maybe you have
to do it
but there
if we were to fast forward to that in
game that you highlighted i mean is it
so easy you mean at first sight it looks
tremendously easy for
okay liam actually decides not to do
that instead he
doubles up and uh
attacks the light square bishop yeah so
he has
hit this piece this bishop i think has
been begging to move the whole game so
it's going to be very grateful it's
given that little nudge and it will
happily jump out the way gaining time
against the white rook and now we will
see this kind of transition
and suddenly where do you put this
bishop are they allowed to offer draws
no uh yeah how old are you i just want
40 if i were
to move 40 right okay i should i should
obviously know that but um
because this is the kind of position
where
you know barring any blunders i'm it
should be a draw right i mean because as
you said all the pawns on one side of
the board and you have to have fantastic
pieces to win this but i i don't think
shouldn't be enough i don't think it's
enough i don't think it's enough but you
can have your fun that's why trying you
could try it out yeah you know
attack the rook as liam's done and then
you attack the bishop and you keep just
asking questions to magnus know what are
you going to do with your pieces because
i mean black knights they're not great
let's face it they're this perfect
nights none of them can move just don't
let your pieces be taken
then you should be all right it would
require blunder from magnus i think
william to win this game also liam is
now down on the clock by two minutes i
don't think he would be too unhappy with
the draw here either so
magnus has solved his problems yeah i
mean you could see bishop c3 and rook go
back now but yeah a dance between them
potentially just to just
just uh get the draw here yeah so it
looks like this one is going to fizzle
out but
it was just that retreating move people
i don't know what it is it's the magnus
effects i've been there myself against
magnus we take negative decisions
i think liam just wanted to play it safe
and
okay after this last capture we're
definitely going to see a draw now
everything is just going to get hoovered
off the board
uh we see bishop and knight disappear
uh we see the remaining bishops
disappear it's just three versus three
on the same side no past pawns
yeah that draw yeah it's it's funny that
you say people play safe against magnus
i mean that that's good
yeah
it's understandable but in a match
situation the only way you can win is by
winning so you have to you know if you
get a good position you have to try and
push it as much as you can one thing
that you mentioned the niche is not
doing uh enough really and i think uh
liam went for this kind of ending and it
was yeah i mean that bishop retreat was
just negative wasn't it a negative idea
i was just forcing this type of drawers
position and look how symmetrical this
is now the pawn structure the kings
is just going to move his king back and
forth one of my criticisms is that
earlier on when he had the bishop i feel
like yeah okay ultimately it was a draw
but he could have pushed it a little bit
harder here this was just easy stuff for
magnus i saw two pack up there i did two
again that was a bit too packed wasn't
it about a podcast as well maybe
listening to podcasts while playing in
one of the top tournaments in the world
that's impressive for game two between
magnus and liam it is also a draw they
are